hello in this video I would talk about
cop 1 and cop 2 coated vesicle mediated
ear to ecology transporter so the
products that are formed in a factory
need to be stored and sorted out in a
warehouse from the warehouse the product
will be delivered to a city a Dockyard
or village or etc to a different
locations
similarly inside our cell there is a
production factory there is a warehouse
and there are seven demanding places
where the products of the factory should
be delivered now our production house of
the factory is the ER whereas our Goldie
is a big warehouse where things are
sorted out and there are multiple places
for example mitochondria lysosome and
even something needs to be secreted out
of the cell so those are places of
demand where the factory product need to
be delivered for example a specific
lysosomal enzyme which is folded in here
is moved to coal key and in the coal
game it is specially specially tab such
that it could be delivered to lysosome
now there are two type of transport
between year and goal key because our
production house and the warehouse
should be communicating with each other
all the time and there is one
anterograde transport and another is
retrograde transport each is mediated by
different type of physical as if there
are different trucks which goes from the
production factory to the warehouse and
there are also different variety of
trucks which goes from the warehouse to
the factory so these are internal rate
and retrograde way of transmission or
physical transmission now from the ER to
the golgi which is imperial transport it
is mediated by cop to coated vesicle and
in a moment we would look at how the cop
to coat is assembled in the ER membrane
there are specific gift protein
which are gtps which are GTP exchanging
factor proteins gift proteins now one
such that is SAR one keV it actually
activates SAR one GDP into servant GTP
in a gtp-bound form SAR one is activated
SAR one is a monomeric G protein it
plays important role in code SME now SAR
one binds with other core proteins such
as say 24 say 23 and helps to associate
with the carbon and after that other
code proteins such as SiC 13 and 631
assembles and forms the cop to mediate
cop to mediated codes and that
ultimately leads to fish physical
binging and release of the cop to coated
vesicles from the ER membrane and they
are ready to be delivered to the colony
so this cop to coated vesicles are
comparable to the truck which are
delivering stuff from the production
factory to the warehouse now there is
another phase of transport which is
known as retrograde transport from
congee to ER maybe let's say think about
that some faulty products which
mistakenly move to the warehouse need to
be bring back to the production factory
again so in that situation this
retrograde transport is very important
and the retrograde transport is mediated
by a specific GTF specific gtp is
activator protein and also a specific
gift protein which is known as a RF give
the eruv give activates small GTP is a
RF and converts is to activated
gtp-bound form now once a RF is
activated it binds with specific coat
protein subunits such as say five post
one and sec 22 and serially it binds to
the cargo and forms a vesicle that would
be
that would be burn it out and that
vesicle is cop-one coated vesicle which
would be transported from khalqi back to
the ER so this is a retrograde transport
I hope this video was informative and
you enjoyed this video if you liked my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you